okay brace yourselves in his first three
days as president Trump lied five times
in what I would consider a big-league
way there's a lot lots of little lies
that we don't even have time for today
but already five major lies from Trump
and what's scary about this is that a
lot of the lies are about really mundane
disprovable stuff so as president Trump
here is a list of Donald Trump's lies so
far since his inauguration on January
20th number one he said that god
prevented rain it's already crazy Pat he
said that God prevented rain during his
inauguration speech it's actually not
true quite the opposite is true the rain
started as Trump started his speech I
guess we could also call it alternate
sunshine it wasn't rain it was
alternative sunshine or something like
that choosing to lie about the weather
of a televised event yeah you're sort of
going out on the limb there aren't you I
love how it's a lie not because he uses
God to support his claims yet just on
the fact that it was raining
yeah Beach of course yeah then we could
say well does God really control the
weather number two the inauguration
crowd stretched to the Washington
Monument that's been completely debunked
and untrue we talked about that
yesterday
number three Trump said that the
inauguration crowd was one to one and a
half million people debunked that
yesterday small attendance smaller than
prior inauguration smaller than the
protest attendance the following day
line number four from Trump again we're
only about 96 hours into this presidency
line number four from Trump he claimed
that he is the person who's been
featured on the cover of Time magazine
of the most times of anybody claiming 14
to 15 so sort of two lies there number
one Trump was only featured on Time
magazine's cover 11 times and number two
it's nowhere near the record Richard
Nixon on the cover of Time magazine 55
times and lie number five from Donald
Trump we'll deal with this more at the
end of the show Trump has again claimed
that three to five million undocumented
immigrants voted for Hillary Clinton of
course just no evidence of that
whatsoever can you imagine if President
Barack Obama had bragged about being on
magazine covers even if it was accurate
which it's not here
it would have been eviscerated by
Republicans yeah that's the thing I mean
some of these lies are over issues that
are so trivial that people like
President Obama or even President Bush
wouldn't even bother to delve into I
mean you were just elected president of
the United States I mean this was a very
humbling and a great honor for you
you're sullying the moment this will be
imagine the lie list after a month I
mean we're 96 hours in folks and again
the content of the lies is not the
important thing in fact it's more
disturbing because these are lies about
really mundane stuff and Trump isn't
doing it casually he's making a big deal
out of a lot of these issues and lying
about them he had Sean Spicer his press
secretary out there lying on national TV
about the crowd size stuff none of these
lies individually are significant what
is significant and horrifying is that
Trump and his team including his press
secretary are doubling down about
demonstrable provable lies this is not a
mistake Pat this is part of the strategy
if you constantly say outlandish stuff
and there's a constant stream of
untruths it becomes totally normal to
some and less crazy to others and then
you can't really be sure about anything
it's actually a strategy even if it's an
unconscious one and credit to the media
who was actually able to call him out
for his lies and some of our some are
going in the direction of calling these
things miss truths and falsehoods yeah
you have to call it out when you see it
these are lies yeah alternative facts
maybe I mean it's it's so far it's the
word of the Trump presidency so far the
phrase of the Trump presidency
really disturbing that the lies are
about such mundane stuff if you're gonna
write to me and say David these are
mundane things that's why I'm so
concerned about it